I'm Laura Ingram and this is Ingram
angle from Los Angeles tonight
we have the ice bag
yeah we have the ice bag it's going to
balance on my leg I promise you if you
hear something crashing that's what it
is
Reality Bites that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now how many of you are feeling more
positive about your family's finances
do you feel like you're getting ahead
financially or do you feel like you're
falling behind I pay over twelve hundred
and thirty dollars in rent alone if I
got two kids I'm taking care of so
anything it can help me out right now
very high eggs five dollars and up milk
five dollars a gallon bread with what
four dollars for just a loaf of bread
it's really ridiculous we paid 8.99 for
a dozen eggs it's a struggle for any
family because the price of food is
really outrageous when I first moved
here Ren was you know relatively cheap
now it's like you really got a happy
secondary third job like tries to keep
up with Ren
well despite all of this Biden thinks
you should be feeling pretty upbeat
just this morning we got some very good
news about the American economy and I'm
not sure and I mean it's sincerely the
news could have been any better
it's been any better
now I don't know what's lower at this
point his own pulse or his ability to
read the pulse of the American people
because according to that right-wing
outfit NBC News Americans are in fact
wildly pessimistic about where we're
headed
71 percent of the country say that we're
on the wrong track now that's the eighth
time in the last nine surveys dating
back to October 2021 that the number has
been above 70 percent
Now NBC itself is saying that we've
never before seen this level of
sustained pessimism in the 30-year plus
history of the poll
heck of a job Joey
yes indeed Reality Bites
now while The Tick Tock types entertain
you with animal videos and they push
trendy makeup tricks
the angle treats you like smart
Americans because you are smart
Americans now last night we reiterated
that the Biden regime's goal is to lower
not raise your standard of living
and they believe that America must
become poorer to advance their power
grab for climate change
and now we have proof that their plan is
working
now you are not going to believe the
numbers that we're about to show you
you're not going to see them anywhere
else the IMF just released its updated
GDP outlook for this year and for next
year and it looks like Americans are
right to be gloomy
now look at our change in GDP from a
paltry two percent in 2022 to 1.4
percent this year
down to one percent in 2024 this is
Criminal
now post covid had the election gone the
other way under Trump now our economy
should have taken off and would have
taken off like a rocket ship
now look at also this Europe declines
too from 3.5 percent last year to 0.7
percent this year ditto for our
neighbors to the north 3.5 percent down
to 1.5 percent this year and next
but looky here
where's China headed a huge jump in 2023
and it taper off a little bit in 2024
but still that's four and a half times
our GDP
and that dip in 2024 is probably because
we're just not going to have the money
to buy as much of their junk that we buy
now
okay so here are the cold hard facts
number one
the Euro countries did better than us
even with their declines in 2022 and
will still do better than us in 2024
shocking
Canada did better than us in 2022 and
even with its declines its GDP is going
to beat ours both in 2023 and in 2024.
okay that's Justin Trudeau just to
remind you number three China did better
than us in 2022 and is going to do much
better than us in 2023 and 2024.
but wait a second what about Russia
I seem to remember assurances that
Biden's tough Ukraine war sanctions
would Putin
who chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences this is going to impose
severe cost on the Russian economy both
immediately and over time
scary and then the media took debate on
the oligarch angle
those of us of a certain age all
remember the Lifestyles of the Rich and
Famous theme song and host Robin Leach
with his champagne wishes and caviar
dreams but this week it's vodka wishes
and borscht dreams and they're being
shattered and France authorities have
seized a yacht owned by Igor sessions
and also ceased by Germany as a yacht
owned by Alisha usmanov it's called the
klepto capture task force enforcing
sanctions and seizing Yachts from
Russian oligarchs will it put the
pressure on Putin
put the pressure on Putin okay so what's
the report card on this Grand sanction
scheme and get the oligarchs game A year
later
Now by 2024 even Russia is going to be
growing faster than the United States
so chalk it up to another failure for
the regime just as the angle predicted
no one else find it ironic then when we
help make China richer China just turns
around and helps keep Russia afloat by
buying more oil and agriculture from
Russia
and now even the New York Times has to
concede that we were right
Russian trade appears to have largely
bounced back to where it was before the
invasion of Ukraine last February
analysts estimate that Russia's Imports
may have already recovered to pre-war
levels or will soon do so depending on
their models
whoops
yet overall things are going exactly as
Biden and the folks in the White House
had hoped for
the United States is slowing and the
rest of the world is moving ahead
now these facts will of course give the
EU and China more leverage over us which
is exactly what the regime wants
now remember again during Trump when the
middle class was getting stronger when
real median income was Rising the DC
cabal the swamp they were miserable why
were they miserable because they loathed
an America whose model is obviously
Superior to anything any other country
could offer
they preferred dependence to
Independence
hopelessness to optimism
but we have we have a news flash forum
even with all the damage they've brought
over the last two years this is still
America and there are enough of us who
will never be satisfied to live in our
knees waiting for whatever crumbs the
government throws us
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else